oh that's a real bear dude the bear has
no ass I don't know where the skepticism
comes
from people
Town hey Tes welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population you
population Chad and JT Chad and JT boys
welcome oh thank fired up right I mean I
feel like you guys are uniquely
positioned to help us understand what is
you've definitely been to more Town
Halls than all of us included we
understand towns and dumb right yeah
yeah like from both sides right so thir
municipality meeting you're like look
there are dumb people on all sides there
dumb people on all sides what is a
municipality is local government oh dude
I do know a lot about that
yeah I think we should move the hedges
by the park like that sort of people but
for that person it's the biggest thing
in the world like when you guys go to a
town hall meeting and just just
completely mess it up uh the three or
four people you have to listen to before
you step to the mic three or four you've
been like hours right you're there for
hours yeah we've seen some really weird
people we saw one guy in Newport Beach
we always talk about who went up there
this was Peak Co he clearly had Co he
was coughing everywhere and sweating
shirtless and very tan shirtless and tan
shirtless at a town hall meeting is a
freaking choice that is awesome and he
he went up there and he's like we need
to settle more conflict sword
fighting it was his testimony I mean can
you argue with him but can we argue with
him that's how he used to settle all
conflicts I liked what he had to say
he's like you know back in the day we
would die by the blade and uh not wrong
today we die by the roller blade like
put shirt on he basically saying people
talk [__] without repercussions and in
his day which I guess in the 70s you
sword fought is that his day the 7s she
was different back then how old was he
like 60s he looks like 50 it's tough to
tell with some of those crazy people you
know will do sun and
cigarettes Sun cigarettes and sword play
my day it was swords and fondue like
what how old are you and he's like I'm
33 you're like whoa dude he's the only
regular at Medieval Times yeah yeah are
you ordering anything today Richard nope
here for the game the usual the US you
should never say medial times the usual
and then be like we know what it is is
Dale fighting how do you know their
actual names all right the turkey leg
all right here's the deal we get stories
sent To Us by our awesome fans you can
send it we're still doing it on X Dan
let's maybe in the new year X is a good
I I hate I hate X in general but it is a
good Delivery Systems would be as well D
vankirk scar brothers and just hashdump
people toown and then we know maybe we
can move it to thread all right let's
should we get into this one this was
sent in by Josh ma m m m m o u a t
thanks at Josh MO and this was sent in
uh July you ready for the headline you
guys here it is China Zoo denies
allegations already if a zoo is denying
allegations that they had sex with the
bear stop this is kind of great because
I feel like this left the gate open this
happens in Asia a lot now okay China Zoo
denies allegations that star attraction
is just a man in a sunbear costume o
have you guys seen this seen the videos
of this no I haven't seen it there's
like a bear that's like that's doing
very Human Action like standing up and
it looks like he's got I want to say
like Pockets underneath I don't know
he's like vaping like like not
vaping it's R's eyes as he looks out I'm
read the sun right okay here we go and
it's said he did
this G gang symbols are like slow down
yeah he's affiliated with his with his
spw he did that with his paw it's a
barely believable sight oh my God I hate
this I hate it that's top in a video
that's gone viral a black colored bear
at a zoo in China can be seen standing
on its two hind legs on the precipice of
a rock feature and interacting tour
interacting with tourists by waving its
paws so if you are a guy bear would
never do this right he's like the shony
bear like uh Roy Jr had that job where
he had to go out in front in the bear
suit like wave people into the
restaurant that's I've actually I have
seen the videos and I thought the bear
was real so now you feel a little duped
yeah Bears don't wave
tradition they do do they how would I
know I saw Grizzly Man once I have no
idea yeah I mean I've seen a lot of bear
action on TV and like you clearly know
that it's a like when they're sitting up
you're like whoo dude that's super weird
this thing was standing on its hind legs
it was like a guy
Dan like a stepdad waving to his kids
anatomically do they have this movement
in their repertoire like do they have an
El they pronate yeah that's thank you so
much yeah I'll have to rethink all my
bear
interactions you guys ever interacted
with a bear for real I was in Tahoe and
this one gave me a pound but just gave
you one of these yeah he's like what's
up dude I'm a black
bear he was like wait are you going in
the convenience store remember there was
that bear that went in the convenience
store and just got that like after you
dude yeah I thought that's just what
happens in T is this like a hit job by
like the American government to like
undermine CH which is great cuz we're
like look they have Tik Tok and it's
definitely working
take one zoo at a time that's our policy
is the uh the zoo policy had bad luck
with animals from China that we have
however that's true for some reason dude
I feel like the bear would be smoking a
Sig yeah exactly Bears around the corner
during his break he's to what
bear recreating that skyscraper poster
from New
York eating lunch from a pale Bears used
to be tough man they different day
remember when bears used to smoke and
settle things with swords all right
however there's apparently more of the
meti at the sunbear exhibit at the Hang
Xiao Zoo which is reportedly a popular
tourist section the nen who posted the
video is convinced that the quote
talented bear is actually a human in a
costume reported the hangs out daily the
zoo on Saturday Deni the charge like
what if you're the guy who has to speak
for or woman who has to speak for the
zoo just be like that's not what do you
mean why why would we do that adding
adding that the temperature on the day
the video was taken was 40° C and A
person wearing a suit would not be able
to tolerate the heat that's their excuse
that's it interesting it was pretty hot
so I mean I really call this fire if
it's what's 40° C like
200° it's like 99 that'll melt pizza
cook 40 is like 100°
98 look it up I think it's I think my
guess is it's
81° guess yeah let's guess I think it's
what do you think it is like 200 said
200 I think if I remember from Australia
30 was like I'm going to go with 90 90
40 is 90 yeah I think it's 96 degrees
there so many list what you say 81 D
there's so many listeners who know
exactly I said 100 are you ready 4° is
104° okay so now that's a pretty good
excuse saying good cook a pizza they
pointed to the Bear's humanlike
movements while standing and waving and
what also appeared to
be pants like folds around its rear
while standing commenters on the jimu
article you shouldn't be like pulling up
your fur yeah he has fur hemmed right I
was like yeah why do this dude got
cuffs it's a posture more upright than
human said one another claim bears for
limbs cannot spread out to the sides
this is UND undoubtedly a human being
you guys are right uh one weebo user
come out and I I love that like now you
get all the bear experts like no excuse
me this is what it is that's to me
really funny uh looks like he's wearing
a leather jacket this is not the first
time the zoo in China has grabbed
headlines for raising eyebrows in 2019
yanging wild animal world in shangu a
city in eastern CH in jangu Province
sparked controversy after it asking us
workers to dress as gorillas reported
the BR they've this is so there's
precedent for this fo me once dude right
fool me once shame on me the real answer
is probably the saddest right it's like
well we took this animal out of its
habitat entire in its entirety and the
only species it interacts with is people
so it's just mimicking the movements of
the only sort of now I want it to be a
guy now I want it to be a guy who works
for the zoo get the guy who cleans up
the thing he'll get in the suit be like
more nefarious too could it be like
crisper technology and they've actually
Gene edited Bears to make them more
humanlike I mean that would be
unbelievable almost rather we think it's
there was a bear that fought in World
War II I believe it was a off polish a
Polish Soldier and fought uh with the
Allies decorated I thought it was a
na naar I don't think so no Nazi bear is
like the it's like the sequel to cocaine
cocaine bear I would like to see this
transition to just humans being the
animals at zoos I think that's much more
e well when the aliens get here we may
get that chance
all sudden our whole perception on well
no it's cool to look at them may change
when we're the I hope I get like Primo
real estate like I'm we the lions were
not where the bugs are
yes you hope you get the alien version
of Disney where there're like there a
lot of room for them to run out here
exactly it's fun it's like a living room
setting yeah you know how the um
Penguins will have like it'll like it'll
be like an icy machine decoration like
this looks like ice right like oh yeah
totally this that looks slick anyway
just paint it white they won't know yeah
that's where so here's what the zoo said
about the asking humans to dress as
gorillas in 2019 the zoo defended itself
and said uh that the human gorillas were
special were a special program designed
to entertain tourists on April Fool's
Day oh did you know April Fool's Day was
the thing in China I know we now know it
is international with April Fool's Day
it added that it had not expected the
arrangement to cause a misunderstanding
from visitors that is such a backtrack
of like sort of a good prank prank but
like the old I didn't know you'd be
offended by that is like the
non-apology sorry you couldn't handle
that how about this in 2013 CNN reported
that a zoo in LuHi Hanan tried to pass
off a large hairy dog as a lion what is
happening at China I've seen people do
that with labber Doodles a lot yeah a
visitor told Beijing youth daily that
when she and her son approached the cage
marked African lion they they heard it
parking they were greeted not by a
mighty Roar but a
bark that's great why is the lion
barking why is the lion any you guys uh
in person heard a lion roar you can feel
it
right reverberates body the furry beast
turned out to be a Tibetan Mastiff the
funny also cool enough to just go see a
Tibetan Mas I've never seen one of those
before good money for make good money
for or a guy dressed as a Tibetan M if I
would take that too why is the Tibetan m
on its back leg well we had the guy
dress as a collie with that's right also
the lions like don't show up a lot I've
been to the San Diego Zoo a bunch and
they're never where you want them to be
dogs are way better job dogs will do
tricks you can like get if you throw the
frisbee that lion will go get it
that's other animals in the park were
similarly mislabeled Beijing youth daily
reported that another dog in the wolf
cage and a white fox on display in the
leopard enclosure so like they're not
even don't even know like the signs
don't even match the animals what it is
the park told us Dan you hate zoos I
know you hate zo but a disorganized Zoo
it's even worse it's even worse I mean
let me see if I can uh find the video or
just yeah they're beating us at a lot of
stuff but it seems like we still have
the upper hand when it comes to zoo
entertainment here's Zoo technology
here's the bear look at him look dude oh
oh that's a real bear dude the bear has
no ass I don't know where the skepticism
comes from I also think it's a real bear
it's 100% a real bear people like oh a
bear is supposed to look like this that
is a my that's an Asian just Clap That
is a that is a that bear is built like
deadlift shrimp he's got he's got shrimp
arms watch him clap look at this clap
dude that is that's 100% a bear you
think that's a bear Jay what you think
that's 100% a bear no no that's 100% a
person in a he's got wrinkles on the
back it's a different it's completely
different type of coat look at this look
at it it come on he's like bowing just
that Dismount is a completely animalred
I'm just more yeah I think he's just on
the wrong diet you got to feed him
better on that cage diet yeah exactly Fe
right all right there you go he's a
vegan bear so that's uh Story number one
down in the books we'll tell you guys
how you can uh follow these guys at the
top of segment too and what's going on
with us hey it's dumb people Town Chad
and JT here with us we'll be right
backck around sound
there's hey guys welcome back to the
show Chad and JT are with us before we
tell you kind how you can check out
their awesome podcast and all the videos
and cool [__] they've done if you love
Dum people town you will love what these
guys do period period exclamation point
all that stuff let's tell them what we
have going on in our stuff so if this
comes out before the new year which it
might uh we are uh going to be in
Portland Oregon on the 4th at uh helium
one night one show let's sell this
freaking thing out right the next night
we're doing the wet City Comedy uh
Festival in uh Seattle at the crocodile
then at the beginning oh then we're
going to be in Alaska we're going to be
in Fairbanks Alaska which I love so much
great town really Co people on the 18th
of January and then the uh beginning of
February we are back in Denver at The
Comedy Works South beginning of March
we're at uh at Markley's Comedy Castle
in Detroit and then beginning of April
we're at Acme in Minneapolis and then
the end we're going to do uh moon tower
moon tower so in in Austin end of April
good stuff coming up super.com you can
see all those dates and whatnot dudes
tell us like how can our fans support
you guys and watch you and enjoy your
stuff D well we have a podcast going to
Chan JT all things comedy love it uh we
have new tour dates coming we ours are
finished but we we'll be back on the
road in February you get tickets to Chan
j.com we'll be in Orlando Tampa nice
Miami Florida baby um
Tempe um Texas on there too Texas great
I love it San Francisco Sacramento and
more ceming nice and you guys both do
stand up do you then do do you do any
live podcasting or whatnot or come on
stage together and do stuff as you go
how does it work we do a Q&A at our at
our live show at the end so that'll be
like 20 minutes that's always super fun
it gets Rowdy it gets Rowdy what do what
do things keep coming up that people
want to know like what is like for you
guys one of the funniest things and I'm
sure you kind of have done it so much
that you now have answers that are
really funny that can go with what they
ask you they ask us about butthole
sunning a lot cuz that was a part of our
our series and then they ask us we we we
did a lot for small penis support so
they ask us a lot about how small our
penises are that's great are you asking
for you or for us like who are you
asking for a friend yeah I don't I think
they feel we'll get like really uh
revealing dudes who are like I have a
really small penis and they just want to
connect
and and they're always like really
they're trying to connect with their
penis is so always like a really
handsome guy who's like finally I get to
be out in the open about this I love you
giving really good-looking dudes with
small penises a chance to be who they
are that's our demo that is your demo
that's your mission statement yeah yeah
wa one guy showed up with his mom you
know we we came out with some shirts
that say I have a small penis or I have
a small dong and he's with his mom
wearing the shirt that's great knew knew
from the beginning yeah she knew it was
going to happen before she like I made
you that way yeah she bought him the
shirt that's great honey honey let the
world know yeah let them know let them
know
Chad andt.com again check out the
podcast subscribe to it you guys will
love it and just follow these guys and
watch them live Dan should we jump into
another story you ready send it by Brew
pounder at Brew pounder here we go
person prowns Bru such a dumb story in
the headline alone hiker brings snake
home to show kids ends up in the
hospital of course you going to love
this my kids do you know what also the
snake do you know what also works just
taking a picture take a picture guess
what I saw same level of enthusiasm from
the kids picture versus SN dud let's
zoom into it let's zoom in and look at
and as a parent of kids he probably
brought if they're teenagers he probably
brought the snake home and they wouldn't
even look up they're like look at this
snake cool look at this snake my God
like this dude's like guys guys wait up
I want to get something for my kids real
quick how do you even get that down off
the mountain do you just put it around
your back and just he's got it around
his neck
like friendly friendly seems really calm
and the kids kids won't look up from
their phone texting yeah that's cool D
great dad Dad look at it it's biting me
look at it that's great dad that's
awesome co co co an unidentified hiker
in Australia hey it's biting me can you
just not can you just not just leave me
alone for five minutes just not hiking
in Australia too that's already like I
thought everything was hiking in AUST
you guys been to Australia I have yeah
oh yeah you live there so like
everything can kill you in austr
Australia yeah strad broke Island have
you been there no no dude there's I
think they have like nine of the 10 most
poisonous snakes there we were there we
were there we it was like a you know I
was there for college for like 3 months
but we were there and they they're like
here's a trip you know weekend trip to
strap broke Island you're like great
yeah and they're like you know every
poisonous snake lives here and I'm like
no thank why are we planning this walk
everybody just walks around waiters yeah
everything it's like 10 times bigger
there too there's bats flying around
huge spiders SP like eating cows you're
like I an unidentified high carart in
Australia was quote extremely lucky
after being bit by what he thought was a
harmless Diamond python okay I don't
even you just told me there's a diamond
can't buy them harmless they're always
harmful unless the snake promises you
unless he's got a
good so nice he was like sleeping I'm
not like the other snakes I've seen a
lot of these dad's like I I think this
is just a guy and a snake out come on
we're not in China you're not going to
fool me again
China extremely lucky after being bit by
what he thought was a harmless Diamond
python which he had captured and took
home to show his kids if I got bit by a
garter snake I'd be like it's over it's
over I'm start saying goodbye to my
family and like it's even though that
like that's not going to do anything to
you I you know it's like people do you
guys either one of you own snakes I'm
not you did ball python yeah you had one
yeah cream python did it just naturally
die or you were like you're free now
dude good question uh we we had him in
college and then our buddy Mason took
him and Mason's kind of a wild card we
him really hurt from him since okay all
right but he might have Harry and the
Henderson the cat or the snake you might
have been like you're free just get out
of here yeah yeah yeah yeah so we don't
want you here don't you see you don't
belong Slither away so you never heard
from Mason again Mason could be dead I
me it's just guys who own snakes never
get any more validation in life than
when they go to a highly populated
tourist attraction that is like for
every person who's judged them or the
family that they don't speak to they
just have to go to Bourbon Street and
they will find so much validation for
this is like the greatest sound they can
ever hear is
whoa yeah did you see that yeah like
most people with the pet that they love
you have to be very cautious like is it
cool if I like pet your dog but with
Snak are like take it take it you want
to hold he's fine he not feel how heavy
he is no I don't want to this is this
guy is like every drunk white girl whose
friend is so drunk that she's passed out
in a bush he's saying to everyone he's
fine he's not fine he's biting you and
you're going to die yeah it's the
negative impact of my octopus teacher
everyone's trying to put friend
Wildlife wild like this could be my new
therapist this snake my snake's not
going to give you a hug my snake
therapist yeah my snake therapist you
tell him all my problem he gets it yeah
he gets me you guys don't get me kids
are like whatever dad whatever cud lot
of cuddle therapy with a snake did you
guys read Britney's book no saw not yet
it's not Christmas from she talks about
the snake and you remember that iconic
performance snake super hot um but I
guess the snake was like starting to
choke her a little bit and she's
freaking out she I can't
believe toxic this snake was Toxic by
the way don't let that comment go under
the [__]
but that's how she finds out she's into
that kind of God damn it I hate that I
love it so much unfortunately it was a
case of mistaken identity as the reptile
turned out to be a poisonous
broad-headed snake which looks very
similar to The Diamond python hey don't
pick it up take a picture of it yeah
right pick it up if there's even a
question don't by the way and I'm so on
the snake side you are literally walking
into his house and picking him up like
don't do it not do it the incident
occurred last Wednesday just love that
reference in the New South Wales
Southern Highlands as reported by Yahoo
Australia okay reputable Source what
what level of Yahoo do you think is
still operating at Peak Performance and
also in what country right like Yahoo
Australia is some guy living with his
ant like that's Yahoo yah could have had
it all they really could they really
could have they were like The Prodigy
they're like we're going to dominate
Google and you're like I think they like
s they were like offered at like 4
billion denied it sold at like 500
million then the prison bought them like
resold them for like 50 million or
something it was an Inc I mean I'm
directionally correct all over the place
yeah I I just wonder where Yahoo is
still thriving hopefully they writing
stories about guys getting bit by snakes
they they when they took away the
exclamation point yeah dud me too I'm
like you're not excited enough Yahoo not
Yahoo no we're not happy any you wanted
a question
the guy might have been using Yahoo when
he found out what kind of snake it was
himay he's like I don't trust B anymore
after that bat incident let me look it
up on Yahoo it says it's fine everyone's
like use Google he's like I'm going to
use Yahoo I'm loyal I'm loyal I got yeah
I know I've got my own source no he's
like I'm going to Google it on Yahoo
it's like no you can't you know je still
works via Yahoo you can ask him bro the
man was hiking with friends when he
spotted the reptile and captured it when
he was bitten he didn't think anything
of it until returning home and becoming
violently ill which he got bit captured
that alone should be like you know what
this guy doesn't want to be or drive
straight to the hospital that too the
the dish the cuz you know we had friends
who were like I really think Michael we
should get this look day he's like it's
fine or if you're gay find the hottest
dude if you're straight find the hottest
woman and say you need to suck the venom
out of this I'll take I'll take anybody
you need to suck the venom out of this
and it's like but you got bit on your
arm oh [__] wait no no no here's the
deal do you think that Marvel movies
have gotten people to think that like
this is gonna give me super this is my
origin story right what's the worst that
could happen I become a superhero not so
bad I start to like be able to see the
future or to me brother to me you are
what's up we're just in the middle of a
podcast here
already hey guys or in the or in the
middle all good all good all good or the
truth of the matter is like you're like
I if I got bit by
something and if it was like Marvel
Universe I'd be like um great now I have
to fight like I got to add that cuz I
would still want to do comedy and
[__] fight crime how give up your
time what's your priority right you have
to like tell your family I have to go
out tonight and they're like are you
doing comedy no I have to fight crime
you did comedy last Wednesday and last
Thursday and now you're going to fight
crime tonight you can't do it you're
going to have to tell them no yeah Ray
go ahead hold on go ahead oh yeah you
never really think about the burden of
having to fight crime too much being a
superhero looks sick but then when you
have to go fight crime MH every night
look for it find it and every crime that
happens that you didn't stop is a crime
you probably could have prevented if you
were just more committed to the cause
also why is it only night like you
there's no you just take the day off all
those people are like oh most crime
happens at night sure plenty during the
day that that's why a lot of them do
ader all now that's right it's a real
problem well the truth is like you I
mean every superhero is like super cut
so you could either fight and you just
get cut just straight away fight crime
and be that in that good shape or go to
spend that time at the gym it's like
either you're at the gym or you're
fighting crime all day you don't have
any time for friends no time to hang out
no time to like party right what life is
sneaking push-ups and pull-ups in
between busting
crimes just don't tell anybody like
you're that guy working out at the bus
stop like dude what if you're a
superhero in a small town There's no
crime you're like don't spray paint that
dick that's
right hey quit quit harassing
her my sister Ray mcgibbon wrote on his
Southern Highland snake catcher Facebook
page lot of action over there on that
page wait he's got a Southern Highland
snake catcher somebody named Ray
mcgibbon wrote on his Southern Highland
snake catcher Facebook page that
the hiker ended up in the hospital After
experiencing a large swollen hand and
violently vomiting for how many hours oh
what do you think how long do we think
he violent violently I've never
violently although it always feels some
sort of violence in that he this guy's
so dedicated to like being oblivious
that I think it was a long time before
he
was I think it was a couple days couple
days8 finally someone else in the family
was like bro get that check out bro your
hand is the size of a godamn he like no
I feel fine my hand's just big the kids
love it it's funny the kids are
entertained by my Big M like the hand
like the snake this is a
hand it's so Australian what do you
think how how many hours you think he
was violently vomiting I think I think
there lot I think it's very Australian
no it's the fishing chips give him a be
something else Al I told you know
chiple 48 Hours ran what' you say I
think 10 hours 10 four yeah four uh dude
I'm gonna go in between I'm gonna go six
six he was violently vomiting vomiting
before he went to the hospital for 3
hours ridiculous
am I'm fine you guys think something's
wrong with a nurse from bro ball
Hospital phoned mcgibbon to God how
happy was he he runs a snake catcher
page and now he gets the call no Dan
he's got a separate cell phone just for
snake bites it's a black
snake by phone is ringing yeah they
called him to get identification of the
reptile to determine a proper treatment
a photo of the snake was sent to him and
he identified it as a broad-headed snake
huge let me identify it they did find
traces of Venom in the hiker system
after six hours he was sent home to
recover during that time I collected the
snake from his residence got the
location to where they found the snake
and returned it back to its Hab also he
could have said I got the snake from his
residence pied collected his made it
seem like he
I collected the snake from his res well
they usually have the pole thing right
and then there's the little like the
old Hook is that like the thing from
like the Korean Deli when they're trying
to reach the thing high up on sh shelf
you got to get the Clipper you get the
thing clamp it and bring it yeah you got
to clamp The Head and the back after
myself doing the track on and how long
it took to walk in and back the hiker
was extremely lucky to make it out after
being bitten and injected with Venom and
without receiving any f first aid the
hiker is feeling extremely lucky it
could have ended a lot worse than it did
MC gim wrote that all broad-headed
snakes have the potential to cause death
from a bite that its venom is
neurotoxic SN unless coagulants and is
weakly holic litic I don't know MC
gibben shed the story to educate people
so please if you see a snake or any
reptile in the wild admire it in its own
habitat take photos or a video please do
not try to capture it and take it home
by the way again like Jay said kids
probably never looked up from their
phones as his hand was like the size guy
this dad's need to just want to impress
his kids so bad that like it's going to
be worth it guys going to love it it's
funny I think I feel like back in the
day it used to be don't even take a
photo of it people thought that was too
dangerous but now we've moved to the
point where we're like well you have to
film it how are you going to post it on
this guy's snake
Facebook now get my face really close to
it no that's Story number two my friend
Story down was a human in a snake outfit
that never would have
happened or maybe even a worse bite I
could see dude snakes should not my two
legs my kids think the guy in the snake
outfit is cooler than me you're ABY we
love the snake dad all right now give us
a little taste of what we're going to
have uh a little potato chip
uh chi canery I want to chip canip
can that little potato chip chip canery
all right on the other side we'll find
out how you can go see Daniel live and
all the stuff he's got going on uh and
his movie and all that great stuff it's
done people town with Chad and JT is our
guest we'll be right
[Music]
back hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get out of here and before we
do the final story a little chip chip
canery uh Daniel tell us how uh people
can see you and check you out club is
out right now you can check that out
over go to Apple TV you can also follow
uh wi Club on Instagram where you can
and um get a chance to come to the
screening the LA premiere on the 17th so
go see my movie January 17th of January
the 21st I'll be doing shows at SF
sketchfest uh movie Interruption uh
standup and then um a live pen pals Rory
Scoville and I will be doing our podcast
there and oh just other places I'm going
you can go to Daniel van.com I'll be in
DC I'll be in De Moine I will be in Ceda
Rapids I'll be in Green Lake Wisconsin
they loved you in Cleveland you'll be
back there I'm sure you there the best
hilarities is the best club all right so
anyway uh Daniel van kirk.com I love it
all right Jade Last Story let's get into
it all this sent in by carlen mcder at
she Caren unbelievable sender in of
stories couple there's the headline
couple left with trust issues after
opening Walker's crisp packet say it
again couple left with quote trust
issues after opening Walker crisp packet
so so Walkers is the
Brandis chip potato chips know he lived
in Australia so they left with trust
issues after they open the bag here of
chips a pair of snack lovers have been
left in shock after opening a packet of
crisps potato chips in England uh Naomi
mulala mhm and her partner Ralph that's
all they said that's all they said like
so much information about same huge
imbalance in their names right that
doesn't feel right that may actually
foreshadow the imbalance in the
relationship itself yeah it's already
wrong they're already poor it's all
about Malala so Ralph
mulala was like for one year like the
best six man in the NBA Ralph Malala he
was all elbows remember when he like
scored 18 on Ralph Samson all right here
we go Ralph has been settling down to
watch some he and Ralph and her partner
Ralph had been settling down to watch
something on Netflix why do they have to
tell us why do we have to know in the
news watching TV we don't know they
watching Netflix what were we watching
Netflix all right we're putting that no
were we watching Netflix we're putting
Netflix what was the documentary about
that uh Love Cult is that on Max anyway
uh something on Netflix in their South
London flat when they fancied a quick
bag of crisps the how old account
manager how old is this woman oh 36
36 is this the girlfriend yeah how old
is she this is no Mal yeah Mal oh
got to be 33 yeah Mal is in her 30s 35
Jeb was like oh
Mal changes
things Legend yeah we're not talking
about Naomi Clark who's obviously 24
we're talking about we're talking about
Malala here Malala is definitely
41 that's get your answers in she is 29
years
old she's an account manager and she was
beused when they found these two mystery
crisp packets it engineer Ralph how old
is this cat Okay so he's it they're
definitely working at the same company
they're having a relationship that the
company does not know about she's 29 how
old is Ralph yeah 22 22 Robin the Cradle
he's an innocent he is innocent 22 uh
she's 2 what n yeah
34 what do you think Ral I mean Ralph 27
I'm going to say 41 again 41 all right
it engineer Ralph 31 years old okay 2
years old appropriate AG appropriate had
just been down to their local Tesco
Express I'm assuming that's a gas
station yeah we've talked about Tesco to
pick up a sixpack we had the guy who got
the barcode of his Tesco card tto arm he
was in there so much he would just have
him scan his arm yeah all right pick up
a six-pack of Walker's prawn cocktail
crisp see so shrimp cocktail Co chips
chip they're either real shrimp in there
is it just shrimp flavored
dude you get that shrimp D Shri dust
yall have that shrimp dust I'll eat it
all right try it 100% would try I kind
of want to try it when the pair began to
tuck in they discovered that one bag was
full of air and the other just had one
crisp in it oh W they might have won
some sort of competition without
realizing some sort of
contest Willy Wonka remember the
Skittles you guys remember the gray
Skittles I would feel I'd be like we won
something babe we're not the gray
Skittles thing yeah there was a gray
Skittle thing like in the 9s if you got
a gray Skittle what did you get it's
like you needed a gray Skittle and then
like some other deal and then you could
like send in I don't you'd
win isn't gra Skittle what killed all
those people on G Game of Thrones scale
so close so so a lot of people do that a
lot of people do that people always
jokingly complain about the crisp and
air ratio in Walker packets so why are
you buying them right people are always
like got a huge problem they put too
much air in these and there are
definitely some potato chip
manufacturers that put a lot of air in
there oh yeah oh yeah there's like a
quinoa like blue corn tortilla chip that
they sell at Gelson's here the bag is
completely clear and I respect it
because you look at it Ming around this
is this is 60% full and I know exactly
what I'll buy you know what you're
getting there's no lie here hon sniders
mini uh pretzels unsalted pretzels sure
I think they put too many pretzels in
there all the way to the top there's no
like distance and air at the top you
open it and you're like in my pretzel
you're in my face it's like when a
bartender it's like I always start to
wear this when I bartended it's like
when a bartender gives you a drink that
you're like oh I need to drink some of
this on the bar like a like like an
alcoholic dog yeah cuz you're like if I
pick this up we're just it's just going
to be just a like a blood trail turning
around to go to the but like to me I
literally I'll bend down and I'll just
like all right I'm going to drink some
of this real quick this is
too if this tells you how drunk the
person is who is trying to drink it out
of the cup without picking it up do you
do with your hands behind your back like
you're bobbing for Apple well you're
super druc when you get done you go Tada
like or you scoop scoop
scoop sco your hand and drink it down or
wash it over your face you treat it like
a water well I got it uh no my thing is
when I go to a bar and and a bartender
without asking me is like I made it
extra strong for you and I'm like
sometimes you don't want I don't want
itra strong yeah you're projecting I
want the alcohol you wanted it extra lot
times that balance of whatever the mix
is or whatever is right like that makes
it tast on the bartender code either of
you guys ever a bartender no no so the
bartender code we never were Dan you did
it but like the bartender code is like
everyone's an alcoholic all right and
everyone wants more everyone wants more
so just keep pouring it and that's my GI
to you or if you don't like him like
dude Dan I think High Noon is a little
strong I love a good high I'll take a
all damn day oh my God I love a good
they wish it was high 9 a.m. I get mad
when I walk in they're like we do white
claws I'm like cool you guys are selling
$7 cans of malt liquor like dude that's
true I I when I was started drinking
white claws I was like yeah it's good
for you it's Seltzer SZ getting hydrated
just Old English you just maltt [__]
Lor that's why they it's all a gas
station hi we'd love to have you you
know what whiteclaw I'll change
everything I said if you want to join
uh fight for us fight between the two of
you I'd like to see you fight to the
death if I can air in grievance too I
think kettle chips has too much air too
much air thank you for having the guts
to say that thank you having theage your
name on it dude that's huge right but I
do if you want to
sponsor sponsor dumb people down
too Jo podcast sponsorship could be a
try partnership all right so this is
what she said mumala we had Netflix on
and whilst Ralph went to get us a snack
that's whilst he started shouting my
name saying I won't believe this he
started shaking the bag and there was
shout like screaming for her shouting
like that kitchen scen in six sense
where all the cupboards are open he's
like freaking out there's a polter guy
right get in here you got to see the you
won't believe this oh there was one
question by the way you won't believe
this is like there's a dead mouse in
there you know what I mean you won't
believe this is like one crisp like calm
down how is this in the newspaper I'm
with him this is like the last like he's
had it the it's just yeah it's Michael
Douglas falling down this is the thing
that sets me off I'm just like I've been
betrayed by life enough now I'm on the
war how dare you there's nothing but air
done it's just air allir this would be
in the buildup of Michael Douglas by the
way and this movie if it starred uh
Michael Douglas as Ralph would be called
Nothing But air nothing but air uh so I
started filming we saw One Singular
crisp in there we were in stitches and
we got to the second packet it was just
air but you didn't pick it up and go man
this feels like
nothing single rattling he bought
six no no he bought the sixpack so it's
probably encased in plasting and just
picked it up and he doesn't know good
defense so and the truth of matter over
overed you definitely want to bring the
like they opened it up and there was no
back so now you can't go back there and
be like there was nothing in here went
through this I bought a I bought a thing
off of eBay and something told me I'm
like video yourself opening it up that's
right and I did and it was it was broke
and I'm like hey I mean what do you like
they had written like their name or like
a thank you deal and I'm like this is
unre like you can't there's you can't
have opened I couldn't have opened it
already I think I did because this thing
the Tesco Express or whatever I mean
your Trader Joe's whatever so it pays to
be nice to everyone and be cool to
people so that they know you at the
thing so that you can come back and be
like yo man I get stuff here all the
time this was completely empty and if
they're good and cool they' be like grab
another one man yeah I also I don't want
to like be a narc but remal and Ralph
like a bit Stony balone when all this
went
down they could have been so H sounds
likeing the squid Game reality
show oh dude there's no chips and like
you ate those 5 minutes long that lines
up too with his reaction of like
[__] you're not going to we got to go
back down stairs to the Tesco this is a
problem in mind World they live above
the Tesco they live right above it only
going all the way back solution you're
not going all the way back there it's
straight down the couple love a packet
of crisps as a snack but this ccent has
left them with some issues with Walkers
Ralph said the next day I picked up a
bag of Quavers I wasn't risking it again
is there a more British name for
chips what's going on with the chip in
England this mayonnaise flavored
mayonnaise flavored qu a bag of Olives
yeah it's a bag of I mean a bag of chips
with mayonnaise like in it that you
could like just peel back and just dude
that sounds delicious I love mayonnaise
mayonnaise on fries o what do we what we
Belgium on everything dude I was
thinking too yeah I thought they had
trust trust issues because well yeah I
thought Ralph was like did you go on a
date eat the chips with your date and
then seal it back he made it so much
worse that she's like who else are you
dating the May walked in there [__]
housed all these and then was like
you're not going to believe this we've
been duped again so like the trust issue
should be between the two them they're
from inside they didn't Discover it
together he didn't videotape himself
opening up you know or record himself
opening up Ralph doesn't even have a
last name no Jesus how you TR guy with
no last name he's a man of Mal Mal it's
left me with is trust issues with my
favorite flavor of crisp when I picked
up the bag of air I was over it it had
gone too far Walkers was it had gone too
far too far guys they tried to push me
before but now they've crossed I'm P my
limit you I've gone too far Walkers was
approached for a comment but are yet to
respond I love it keep your mouth shut
Walkers blame them we will never the
first rule about these crits is we will
we will never have a statement recorded
on the the fact that this got
reported yeah just the smallest
inconvenience of your life you never
think like well I'm going to go talk to
Dallas R let talk to the authorities
this article was written KCRW the
reporter was called into the editor's
office and it's like you know why I
called you here like no no it's article
about the crisp okay what's the what's
the problem what were they watching on
TV I never asked does it matter or get
on the phone and call them or he comes
in and they're like there's nothing in
this article and he's like exactly
that's the point was trying to show you
how frustrating it is to open something
up and have nothing be there yeah you it
great show Friends oh go ahead brother
oh I was I commend Ralph for you know
sticking with them for that long though
know yeah this one the first time the
couple that files a claim against Walker
chips together stay stays together then
every time he walks into that Tesco he's
gonna see their their display their
stuff right there you'll see other
people buying
it he's gonna be like don't do it it
it's a knife in his heart every day
you'll be that guy actually bu that bad
I wouldn't do that would do that I saw a
video of him opening it too blly me for
sure A game A game anyway all right you
guys that is the show that's what we do
it's dumb people Town follow Chad and JT
listen their podcast it's on this
network uh go see them live whenever
they do Daniel see Daniel live and come
see us live and uh oh [__] guys we got
to get back to
[Music]
work